y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
los observadores en france24 esta semana
iremos a túnez o de unos seguidores de
un club de fútbol amenazan con emigrar
de manera ilegal hacia italia para
protestar contra la federación tunecina
que decidió sancionar a su club luego
veremos la complicada relación entre
twitter y donald trump marcada por las
informaciones falsas del presidente de
esta audiencia
estos seguidores del csp están furiosos
desde que la federación tunecina de
fútbol decidió excluir a su club de la
liga 1 recomendando que su expediente
estaba incompleto para protestar contra
esta decisión un comité de apoyo al club
decidió organizar un procedimiento de
migración colectiva hacia italia una
iniciativa cuyo objetivo al principio
era puramente simbólico explica nuestro
observador en el por todavía una célula
encargada de recibir a los candidatos a
la inmigración al cuarto día de las
inscripciones la cifra era casi de 2.000
personas hasta las autoridades apoyaron
esta operación de inmigración
clandestina el presidente de la comuna
hussein a fritz firmó una petición en la
que llamaba a los jóvenes inmigrantes
pero lo que pasó es que durante la
semana del 2 de noviembre una cantidad
importante de tunecinos que no provienen
de la ciudad llegaron al puerto el 12 de
noviembre unos seguidores aumentaron la
presión al pretender que se embarcaban
hacia italia antes de ser alcanzados por
los guardacostas con ese inicio
también hay que tener en cuenta que
desde este verano hay un fenómeno en che
para la inmigración clandestina de las
familias
niños padres madres cruzan el mar y
logran llegar hasta las costas italianas
al menos 5 familias originarias de
chiapas se fueron así y las imágenes
circularon masivamente por las redes
sociales
se pasó lo vive de la pesca y de un poco
de agricultura monta para no tener que
andar hasta el bar y huesos y en el fla
la decadencia del estado y su
incapacidad para solucionar los
problemas en particular a nivel local
hizo que algunos habitantes se
utilizaran la inmigración clandestina
como último recurso de presión
entre el primero de enero y el 29 de
octubre más de 27.000 migrantes llegaron
a esta italia por mar más de 11.000 de
ellos llegaron desde túnez
twiter público 18 advertencias en tres
días en la cuenta detonación para
alertar a los internautas sobre
afirmaciones erróneas hechas por el
presidente estadounidense por ejemplo
sobre estos tres vídeos difundidos por
un medio conservador que cuestionan el
resultado de la elección twitter
previene esta afirmación a propósito del
fraude electoral es controvertida
compartir vídeos engañosos no es algo
nuevo para el actual presidente
estadounidense lejos de eso por ejemplo
en marzo pasado
twitter calificó este vídeo como
contenido manipulado porque está
trancado escuchen el resto de la frase
efe gates donde el software fans 4 yo
bailé prevenía sobre los riesgos de un
enfrentamiento verbal con donald trump
lo cual sólo perjudicaría el debate
político y ningún caso se refería a su
relación en septiembre el presidente
estadounidense también repitió este
vídeo
[Música]
joe biden si puso una canción pero no la
de ese el grupo de hip hop sino la
canción despacito
[Música]
hasta ahora twitter no ha eliminado esos
contenidos engañosos dejando que las
personas juzguen por sí mismas pero el
tema de la cuenta de twitter de donald
trump que cuenta con al menos 89
millones de seguidores será con
seguridad una de las telenovelas de este
fin de mandato
y terminamos con la verificación de la
semana y volvemos sobre los recientes
incendios en brasil que han dado pie
para muchas desinformación es
explicaciones con nuestra periodista
ahmed abul adivinen quién está causando
el incendio aquí será para tumbar el
gobierno evolucionar miren el ibama está
causando el incendio
hola yo
esto debe ser ampliamente compartido
esos bandidos de izquierda están
causando los incendios en vez de
extinguir los deben ir a la cárcel estos
vídeos circularon por las redes sociales
brasileñas acusando a los brigadistas y
los equipos encargados de apagar los
incendios junto a los bomberos de estar
causando algunos de los incendios que
devastan desde hace varios meses en
amazonas y el pantanal una zona húmeda
en el suroeste de brasil en efecto si se
trata de equipos brigadistas en el
primer vídeo son miembros del ibama en
el segundo del inbio son dos institutos
que dependen del ministerio de ambiente
pero en ambos casos si están causando el
incendio lo hacen en el marco de
operaciones de contra fuego o que más
controlado en un comunicado el envío
explica que este método consiste en
eliminar los elementos combustibles en
pequeñas franjas de tierra a través de
la aplicación de fuego y se trata de
entonces de quemar la vegetación seca
antes de que lo haga un incendio para
evitar su propagación en cuanto al
primer vídeo también se trata de una
operación de quema controlada como lo
explicó un agente del instituto por
facebook desafortunadamente la falta de
conocimientos sobre la manera de
prevenir y combatir los incendios
forestales condujo a este tipo de
noticias falsas el medio de verificación
brasileño
detectó varios casos de desinformación
similares que tienen en común atribuirle
los incendios a tres objetivos conocidos
los pueblos indígenas los ecologistas y
las ong la política ambiental del
presidente brasileño es criticada pero
el 22 de septiembre yair bolsonaro
denunció una campaña de desinformación
contra su país relacionada con los
incendios en particular acusó a los
indígenas por los juegos
no dude en visitar nuestra página web
para ver más artículos de verificación
si quieren hacer parte de nuestra
redacción todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla hasta una próxima
oportunidad
[Música]